we are officially living in the upside
down world when i was a kid the
republicans were the party of small
government
and big corporations
the party that took the side of rich
uncle penny bags against the little guy
the party of deregulation the party most
of all of tax cuts
the democrats on the other hand were the
party of big government the party of
soaking the rich the party that assailed
big corporations
and yet today
that script has totally flipped
just yesterday in florida republicans
passed a bill which will be signed into
law today or tomorrow that takes power
away
from disney probably the most powerful
corporation in the entire state of
florida
a bill that will raise taxes on that
corporation and re-regulate not
deregulate re-regulate its relationship
with the state of florida all because
disney opposes a law that republicans
passed that prohibits teachers from
preaching transgenderism in kindergarten
classrooms
that's another big change when i was a
kid democrats were the party that fought
the big cultural battles and won them
republicans were the losers who rolled
over today
it's the republicans going on the
offensive waging a battle to retake
cultural ground getting punched by
disney and then punching back twice as
hard
and today
it's not only the democrats but even the
operatives for open socialists who are
taking the side of the big corporations
even bernie sanders former press
secretary is shilling for a 200 billion
dollar corporation
i know
fashion corporations is popular left and
right these days i'd be careful going oh
my money is on the disney lobby
my money is on the disney lobbyist do
you think those those state legislatures
down in florida are going to bend to the
will of the governor did you see what
jared polis said he'd love a rocky
mountain disney yeah
but by the way the florida legislature
the state senate just passed this bill
to strip disney of its special accident
i'm betting on the big corporations
honey so much for socialism
so much for the little guy
the left is putting their money on big
business against the self-rule of the
american people
it's a cynical bet
it's an immoral bet
and best of all we're seeing this more
and more each day
it's looking like a losing bet for
democrats i'm michael knowles this is
the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from trash
discourse who says if they make a gay
fight club they will automatically break
the first rule of fight club otherwise
florida wins so true so true it's gonna
be very difficult to do that sort of
reboot i don't want to just get too lost
in my own ahead here i don't want to get
too far down this rabbit hole of the
realignment that we've heard so much
about in recent years that the the
republicans or the party of the people
now and democrats have become the party
of the rich i don't want to just be in
my own echo chamber
which so often we are
so i have brought on one of the most
aggressive one of the most progressive
people that i know coincidentally the
host of the aggressive progressive
podcast you've seen him on lots of
television stations fox news in
particular and all sorts of places chris
hahn chris first thank you for coming on
the show
hey how you been man you're looking thin
well thank you very much i i've really
tried to style myself a um what's the
word uh skinny i don't know i've tried
to style myself as sort of skinny that's
just me being jealous man
jealous but i wish i had your hair i
wish i was as thin as you stop it you're
gonna make me blush i
i need a reality check or maybe not
maybe you agree with my take on this
are the
are the party you know we hear so much
in the 1960s that the party's switched
and republicans usually argue against us
are the parties switching now are the
republicans speaking more toward regular
ordinary
mainstream blue-collar issues and are
the democrats showing for the
corporations um no i think uh you know
even if you look at this bill that they
just passed in florida it gives them a
year to kind of work out the details and
i have a feeling in that year
uh ron desantis will be off in iowa
running for governor and the people in
florida are going to say yeah no we
don't want to piss off the biggest
employer in the state of florida
how can we work this out they also don't
want to take on disney's debt which they
would have to do if they reintegrate
disney into that surrounding area
there's some other bonding issues it's
not just the you know uh zoning and
other things they talk about in this
bill there's some bonding issues that
assumingly the people of the state of
florida would have to take on if this
bill actually goes into effect which
will be a year from now based on what's
actually in the legislation
so yeah no i don't think that that will
actually happen and when i hear people
like simone sanders talking about
um you know
i'm betting on the corporation she's
right because they're gonna get their
way here as they almost always do
especially in that state with that
particular corporation quite frankly i
don't want anything to to threaten uh my
ability to enjoy the ben kenobi series
that will be coming out very shortly on
disney plus i'm really looking forward
to that uh so uh you know let's hope i
don't have to pay an extra dollar a
month because of ron desantis attacks on
disney um so you know i i think
ultimately that will happen as for the
don't say gay bill uh as an aggressive
progressive i am happy to see that
democrats have adopted a tactic that
republicans have long used take an early
draft of the law and then paint the
entire law and everybody who supports it
as that for example yeah the green new
deal uh the you know the republicans
found got a hold of a brainstorming memo
from some staffers about maybe banning
meat and that was what the green i think
you and i were debating it at one point
that was what the green new deal became
in the eyes of most americans but chris
you've got at least grant to deal now
you've got to at least grant republicans
went after the green new deal that maybe
they went after an early draft maybe
they've changed their mind the democrats
have changed their mind about some parts
of it but but it was always called the
green new deal it was to bring back this
idea of fdr's major overhaul of the
economy whereas in florida
whatever you think of the parental
rights and education bill it doesn't ban
the use of the word gay it's it's great
that the democrats have adopted this
tactic and branded the bill don't say
you're saying it's politically great
hold on hold on acknowledge the skill
there yeah right
it hasn't it hasn't been the democrats
it's not has been not been their strong
point or at least people other than me
it has not been the strong point of the
national party to take something and say
remember when they said that you weren't
even let them say this in class and they
branded the bill that and now they
painted it with a brush it's gonna be
very hard you know not this year look
this is a good year for republicans
um if this was if this was two years
from now i don't know that ron desantis
would be attacking this part right he
only won by half a percentage point four
years ago but it's a great year for to
be a republican he's got a hundred
million dollars in the bank the
democrats have a messy primary going on
down there probably gonna uh you know
have charlie crist as their as their
nominee and i don't know where that goes
okay uh so so even the environment he's
in he's you know he's using it to his
advantage so you're saying that this is
an interesting point that i actually
haven't heard a lot of people say you're
saying that on the the
d the first bill that we're talking
about that the disney uh take away their
self-governance bill that's going to
raise their taxes you're saying it's
actually kind of cynical i don't think
it's really going to go into effect it's
just a way to get a lot of headlines but
ultimately disney's going to win okay so
it never could go wrong by calling a
political uh attack cynical it's
completely cynical and that's why it's
not taking effect tomorrow but then okay
so let's say let's say i even grant you
the premise then right then le on the
point of the don't say gay bill let's
say i even grant your premise that okay
it's not a totally honest slogan to use
for the bill but it's a good tactic and
it's going to be effective but then what
do you make of this chris 60 of
americans broadly support the parental
rights and education bill the majority
not only of florida republicans but of
florida democrats support the parental
rights and education bill so don't you
don't you have to say but but 70 of
americans oppose the don't say gay bill
remember frank luntz i mean this is the
kind of thing that people you know yeah
you call the parental rights and
education bill people are going to
support it you call it the don't say gay
bill politically it's toxic but i i
guess
so i grant you that point on on the
names but when there there have been
polls actually we conducted one of the
polls that when you take away all the
names you don't even name the bill you
just focus on the text of the bill
people support the provisions
absolutely just like the affordable care
act when you call it you you know people
support almost everything in it unless
you call it obamacare and then they
don't but the affordable care act won
ultimately it did win so i guess what
i'm just asking is isn't this isn't
opposition to this bill even if the
democrats have been smart about the
sloganeering or whatever isn't it
ultimately a loser for democrats to be
on the side of of teaching
transgenderism in the classroom and on
the side of a big corporation that is
not what's happening here what's
happening in this bill even now even in
the bill that passed
it makes it illegal for a kid to talk
about their weekend with their two
parents that might be of the same gender
well it only it only prohibits teachers
from saying things well how would the
teacher then react when one of the kids
in the class say what does it mean that
he has two mommies i mean he said go ask
your parents
well
mike
let's be clear
um the arc
this
you're not going to win the argument
long term
attacking
same-sex couples attacking homosexuals
it's not going to happen but do you
think they're going to win over in
america this this battle has been won
and while there might be a moment right
now based on the political environment
for him to attack further the right to
bolster his base so that he might do
well in iowa i i mean it it's so cynical
it's so bad then let me okay people who
he shouldn't be attacking let me put the
question another way you you've advised
democrat candidates you're obvious your
head is in this all the time so you're
sitting there with democrat presidential
candidates this issue is going to come
up the issue of disney pushing
woke sexual ideologies and specifically
the issue of teachers in kindergarten
through third grade class this is the
thing we keep he keeps going out he's
calling it woke ideology disney
supported their gay employees and there
are many of them who were offended by
this bill sure and as a result as a
result
ron desantis is attacking disney but
will ultimately cost the people of
florida money because now they're going
to have to police disney they're going
to have to assume they're bond debt i'll
go i'll go with all of them i'll go with
all the parade of horribles but by the
way i'm telling you right now i'll put
money on this invite me back this time
next year
this bill will never go into well okay
listen
you might be you might be right before i
let you go we're over as usual but it's
but i need to i need to ask
last time i saw it i was in tennessee i
was getting a hot chicken we were
debating with a national legend i know
we somehow we ended up in a three-person
debate the recording articles that came
out before your mother was born when i
was at clinton my father's i remember it
but i have to i have to ask you this
question so let's say i grant everything
you're saying about the bill it's not
going to go into effect it's this that
and the other thing
if you're advising a democrat candidate
today do you tell them democratic
candidate you went to yale use proper
english please if you are advising one
of those crazy
maniacal
do if you're advising one of these
candidates do you tell them
lean into the florida
education bill defend kindergarten
teachers talking about this stuff or do
you tell them this this is this year the
year of our lord 2022. do you tell them
lay off the bill it's a political leader
today
say gay bill and lean that scores well
and lean into it don't let them call it
the parental rights and education act or
whatever you know like because that is a
different look again language matters
frank luntz is a genius he's an evil
genius but he's a genius in the way he
you know the death tax oh my god the
death tax they're gonna tax me i made a
hundred thousand dollars in my lifetime
and they're gonna take it away from my
kids no it was about people making over
10 million dollars a year
getting a gradual increase and he called
the debt correct
with the byte inflation pretty soon your
hundred grand is going to be on paper 10
million dollars so we'll have to deal
with that
so you've made several predictions here
i we are going to have you back many
times we're going to figure out you look
you might be right i don't know we're
keeping an open mind uh chris where can
people find you uh christopher hahn on
twitter christopher hahn ny on instagram
although nobody cares about me on
instagram i'm another old one i follow
all that i'm always looking for your
story updates i have i have lots of
pictures of my dogs on instagram and
christopherhan.com all right go find
chris thank you so much for coming on
anytime mike thanks for having me all
right now
folks
when you want to
keep your blood pressure down when you
want to protect your life i know
sometimes you get into political
arguments you feel like you're you're on
the verge of losing it well when you
want to protect your life i would
strongly recommend you check out
fabric right now go to meetfabric.com
knowles if you're a parent you know that
kids are amazing and the highlight of
your day and extremely expensive with
fabric protecting your family with term
life insurance is
shockingly affordable fabric was built
specifically for parents to help you
manage your family's financial future
like a parenting pro totally stress free
fabrics new lower prices mean
significant savings over other providers
with great policies like a million
dollars in coverage for less than a
dollar a day
everything is on your schedule with
fabric because it's all online less than
10 minutes to apply you could be offered
coverage instantly with no health exam
required they make it as easy as
possible do the responsible thing you
love your kids you want to make you sure
that your kids are protected that in the
event of something and the craziness
that happens in life
do it you're going to sleep better it
it's the right thing to do protect your
family with term life insurance now in
just 10 minutes apply today at
meetfabric.com knowles that's
meetfabric.comt
fabric.com
knowles fabric insurance agency policy
is issued by vanta's life not available
in new york and montana price is subject
to underwriting and health questions
so
i i have to say i i disagree with
chris's
strategy here i think we basically agree
on the substance of the bill right he's
chris is admitting to me that yeah okay
the bill doesn't really do all these
terrible things democrats are saying it
doesn't really ban the use of the word
gay but this is a good political
strategy so democrats should follow it
i don't think the numbers back that up i
don't think the poll numbers back that
up i don't that's not what that's not
what i'm seeing here and we're gonna
we'll get an answer in the 2022 midterms
the one thing i'm sure of though
i think chris underscores this point is
that democrats
consider this issue of talking about
sexual issues
and specifically talking about sexual
issues with little kids the democrats
consider that
sacred gensake
just the other day
was was literally crying over the
prospect of not transiting the kids
the political
games and harsh and cruel uh attempts at
laws or laws that we're seeing in some
states like florida that is not a
reflection of the country moving to
oppose lgbtq plus communities that is
not what we see in data that is not
factual and that is not where things
stand this is a political wedge issue
and an attempt to win a culture war and
they're doing that in a way that is
harsh and cruel uh to a community of
kids especially i'm i'm like going to
get them i'm going to get emotional
about this issue because that's just
it's horrible
but uh but you know it's it's like kids
who are bullied and
this is like all these leaders are
taking steps to hurt them and hurt their
lives and hurt their families and you
look at some of these laws in these
states and it is going after parents who
are in loving relationships who have
kids it's completely outrageous um but
it is it is a wedge issue sorry i and
this is an issue that makes me
completely crazy um but it is an issue
that um is a political wedge issue it is
not a reflection of where the country is
this is an issue that makes me
completely crazy is the truest statement
that jensake has ever said obviously
she's crazy the woman
is crying
over the prospect
of not
transgendering little kids
this is a
sacred issue to the libs sometimes when
when we talk about this the libs will
accuse us of wearing tin foil hats and
being conspiracy theorists but it's not
the case the libs have been weirdly
obsessed with sexualizing kids for at
least 100 years now going back to
wilhelm reich going back to
leftist intellectuals and theorists who
have suggested that we we need to
acculturate kids in into sexuality in a
different way and at an earlier stage
bernie sanders bernie sanders who was
almost the democrat nominee twice bernie
sanders wrote weird essays in the 1960s
about how we need to sexualize kids and
allow kids to explore their sexuality
and now you've got democrats waging a
national fight over the so-called sacred
right of a five-year-old to be
indoctrinated into weird creepy sex
stuff this is why we call them groomers
okay because they are obsessed
with this issue it's the most important
one to them they care about race they
care about class or at least they used
to i actually don't think they care
about it as much anymore they care about
but sex is the issue
there was an article in the san
francisco standard
san francisco standard is writing about
a tent city of homeless people
outside of the civic center in san
francisco
but they're removing the tent city the
liberal officials in san francisco are
removing this the tent city why is that
well they're doing it here i'll just
read from the article city officials are
demobilizing a city-sanctioned tent
village at city civic center in
preparation for the come back of pride
festivities in june
so the reason they have the tent city in
the first place is because they see
these poor people these poor
people who are in such terrible
circumstances we need to do everything
we can to help them give them public
land give them public resources
don't we let them do drugs let them do
whatever they want they can do drugs
here we'll give them needles we'll do
what whatever they want
unless a bunch of gay guys want to dance
around the street and then sorry see you
guys sayonara we're going to take away
your tents we're going to take away your
needles and we're going to tell you to
scram
when when those two
sacred issues for the left come into
conflict the poor people
the drug addicts
on one hand and then the
the
sexual people on the other the sexual
revolutionaries the sexual
revolutionaries are going to win and
it's a smart bet for the libs it's a
smart bet because sexuality i've said it
a thousand times in this show sexuality
is so important to human nature that if
you can get a handle on that if you can
redefine
sexuality if you can shape sexuality
which the libs have a point here does
begin from a young age so if you can
start to shape that and mold that you
have a much better chance of creating
young revolutionaries this is why the
libs are so upset about the bill in
florida this is why the libs are taking
the site of a 200 billion corporation
called disney right now this is why the
libs are doxing a private citizen who
runs an anonymous twitter account called
libs of tick tock previously anonymous
now we know who she is these the
washington post spent big resources
to find out who she is and to doxx her
they're doing it because it threatens
a central part of their agenda
that's one of the downsides of living in
modernity but there are upsides which is
why you should get upside down the free
get upside app right now use promo code
knowles you will get 25 cents per gallon
or more off your first fill up what get
upside does is gives you cash back
specifically at the gas tank which is
really really important because gas is
through the roof right now and hitting
record highs but elsewhere too
you could get 30 cash back at grocery
stores
you could get cash back at restaurants
at food delivery it's a wonderful app
especially in these really tough
economic times go do it today otherwise
you're throwing money out the window how
do you do it what's the catch
there's no catch there's no catch only
cash back you download the free get
upside app you use promo code knowles
and then
you cash out you can't you can cash out
to your bank account to paypal to amazon
gift cards how however you want to do it
it's really really simple download that
app today get upside use promo code
nulls get 25 cents per gallon or more
cash back on your first tank use that
promo code noel's canon wles what is
that code just like beyonce
k-n-o-w-l-e-s
they're still going after libs of
tick-tock lips of tik-tok a very simple
account all the account does is goes on
to tick-tock finds public videos of the
libs saying and doing weird stuff and
then reposts it to twitter the reason
they do this is because young people are
on tick tock older people are on twitter
kids are on tick tock parents are on
twitter and so parents have no idea what
their kids are seeing all the time
tiktok is a much more addictive social
media platform than twitter is for
instance the average use time of twitter
per day is between three and six minutes
it might even be lower than that the
average user time spent on tick tock per
day is 52 minutes so it's not even close
and libs of ticktock provides this
simple service and says here's the kind
of stuff that you are seeing and and
they've expanded a little bit too
so libs of tick tock would go in and
find videos from other fora from uh
lessons from the classroom to show to
show you what kids are actually being
taught in these schools to just give you
a little taste of the kind of workloads
tick tock is doing you saw it on the
show probably a year ago they went out
and this woman went out and found a
professor at old dominion university who
was normalizing pedophilia
i use the term minor attracted person or
math in the title and throughout the
book for multiple reasons
first of all because i think it's
important to use terminology for groups
that members of that group want others
to use for them
and math advocacy groups like before you
act
um have advocated for use of the term
map
they've advocated for it primarily
because it's less stigmatizing than
other terms like pedophile
a lot of people when they hear the term
pedophile they automatically assume that
it means a sex offender and that isn't
true and it leads to a lot of
misconceptions about attractions toward
minors
i've definitely heard the idea that you
brought up though that the use of the
term minor attracted person suggests
that it's okay to be attracted to
children
but using a term that communicates who
someone is attracted to
doesn't indicate anything about the
morality of that attraction
this is the kind of stuff that the
washington post doesn't want you to see
this is why the libs are trying to shut
up libs of tick tock this twitter
account
because
they know that this stuff is not going
to play in peoria
this is why the libs are very upset
about the bill in florida is because
generally speaking parents have no idea
what's being taught in the classroom
it's happening behind their backs and
they want this to occur for their agenda
but they don't want people to see
anything about it it is very telling
that when
the right then that when the left
attacks the right the left tries to
censor us and tries to intimidate us and
puts words in our mouth that we never
said and when the right attacks the left
we just play their own words verbatim
that tells you a whole lot about the
political battle in the country now the
political operative working for the
washington post who who doxed libs of
tick tock this gal taylor lorenz she is
trying to make herself
into the victim here she goes out
she reveals this anonymous woman's name
occupation religion for some reason
hyperlinks to her physical address then
the washington post deleted that
secretly and and didn't didn't
issue a correction so they just tried to
sweep it under the rug then when they
were called out on it they just just
defended it
this woman now is playing the victim
this woman says quote the amount of
insane stuff that's happened over the
past 24 hours has been unbelievable it's
eye-opening to see how sophisticated and
vicious these coordinated attacks have
become i'm grateful to work at a company
that takes these issues seriously and is
supportive i'm doing great
of course she's doing great she's an
extraordinarily protected member of one
of the most elite institutions in the
country she's she's talking about
sophisticated and vicious and
coordinated attacks because people on
twitter are criticizing her meanwhile
she has been working with the second
richest man in the world at one of the
oldest platforms in america to
target a private citizen for no
journalistic reason other than to shut
this woman up to intimidate her to tell
people hey here's her physical address
sure would be a shame if something
happened to her
because she's exposing what the libs
actually believe
and amid all of this
the smart democrat political consultants
are trying to flip the narrative james
carville he's the guy who talks like a
cartoon character from new orleans
james carville comes out on television
on msnbc and tries to make the argument
that the gop
is just weird
do you think mcconnell is right about
the risk and how should democrats
approach it james
well moscow mitch is up to his usual
tricks you know he he had a quite a few
dealings with the russians and of course
his party about a third of them were
pulling for russia
uh
yes he he wants people that will be
compliant to
to his world view
which is tax cuts for the richest people
in the world and
in tax poor people which is i don't
think it's a very smart idea but the
problem is they are a weird political
party they need to be branded as such
these 26 q anon people
all right that's not that's not
necessarily the extreme i mean these are
people that talk about testicle tanning
these are people that like go to hungary
for conferences these are not normal by
and large a large part of the republican
party is just out and out weird
james carville made three
claims here and they're all
false they're all lies the first one is
that the republicans are colluding with
the russians right that's what moscow
mitch is about and that's not true one
the liberals in this country colluded
with the russians for most of the 20th
century with the soviet union and
chilled for the soviet union and never
apologized for it even once but but even
beyond that
joe biden took the sanctions off of
russia gave russia its pipeline the
nordstrom 2 pipeline which was the
invitation to go invade ukraine joe
biden literally invited vladimir putin
to invade ukraine he said if it's just a
minor incursion that biden wouldn't do
anything about it vladimir zelinski the
leader of ukraine is actually
saying that the reason that russia
invaded ukraine is because of the
lifting of those sanctions so that part
is insane that part is the opposite of
what is true then james carville says
the republicans
what a republican they are out there and
vote a big corporation give a tax cut to
the big corporations that's not true the
florida republicans just voted to raise
taxes on the biggest corporation in
their state one of the biggest most
powerful corporations there the disney
company and the libs are really furious
about that simone sanders is whining and
crying and saying no no please
my money is on the big corporations
so that second part is not not true
either and then the third part the gop
is just plain weird the democrats are
launching a national campaign to trans
little kids to pump little kids full of
puberty blockers and cross-sex hormones
and chop off their genitals
this is a national issue now that not
just some of the fringe lunatic
democrats are talking about but that all
of the democrats are talking the most
mainstream democrats are talking about
it the democrats are up in arms at a
national level because the voters in
florida the majority of republicans and
the majority of democrats voted to stop
kindergarten teachers from preaching
transgenderism to five-year-olds
and you're going to call the republicans
weird have you lost your minds
have you lost your mind so what what
carvill's trying to do carvill's just a
a hack he's a very sophisticated hack
and a very successful hack
but he's no political philosopher this
guy is a down and dirty bare knuckle
political consultant
and he's trying to get a hold of the
narrative for his party
because his party especially looking
into 2022
has completely lost the threat and they
are headed if the polls are to be
believed
for electoral disaster
and they can't win for losing even on
the issues that are kind of gimmies they
keep losing one of them would be this
issue of the masking i'm taking a flight
today this is going to be my i'm going
up to bu we'll be speaking at boston
university tonight the topic of my
speech is teach the abcs not the lgbts
it should be fine i think it's sold out
but there's going to be a standby line
so show up there if the libs pull their
usual shenanigans and stage a walkout or
something there might be some empty
seats so you can go check that out this
evening i'm very excited because i'm not
going to need to wear a mask on the
plane
every time the stewardess turns away i
usually take my mask down but now i
won't even have to pretend i can throw
that silly filthy cloth in the trash and
not have to think about it anymore and
yet
the democrats are fighting to bring the
masks back joe biden is appealing the
the court decision that got rid of the
cdc mask mandate and and now you've got
a doctor on msnbc going even further
she's saying not only should you wear a
mask on the airplanes but you should
bring extra masks and nag everyone
around you to put one on too
if people want to stay safe the best
thing they can do high quality mass and
that when possible carry some extra
masks i know this sounds crazy but if
you tell someone next to you on a plane
pay a 95 and just say or surgical mask
and just say i've got an elderly mother
at home i've got a child with cancer at
home will you please do me a favor
having the people at least closest to
you in that row protecting yourself and
them
can be the best safety so carry some
extra masks with you carry some rapid
tests with you if you're traveling
please
please someone in my row please nag me
to put a mask on i go ahead
and make my day and you hear this doctor
is trying to really pull on the
heartstrings
she's
encouraging people
to whether it's true or not say that
you've got a sick kid or a sick mother
to just try to emotionally manipulate
people into wearing the mask but if
someone did that to me i would say no
i would not do it because my wearing a
filthy piece of cloth on an airplane is
in no way going to have any effect
whatsoever on this woman's sick kid or
sick parent or sick puppy or whatever
other heart-wrenching excuse
she can [ __ ] out of thin air
it won't do anything you could if
someone said that to you you could say
you know i'm so sorry that you're you've
got this sorrow in your life i'm so
sorry that you're going through these
difficult things
my putting filthy cloth on my face on
this tin can flying through the sky is
not going to change anything about your
circumstances i can pray for you that
will be much more effective than wearing
this stupid piece of cloth but i'm not
going to indulge your fact-free neurosis
one second longer
you see a lot of polls going around now
the the associated press put out a poll
yesterday they said the majority of
americans actually support the mask
mandate on the public transportation oh
yes uh 52 or 53 support it and
127 of statistics are totally fake and
you know i just don't believe it
i guess that's what it comes down to i
just don't believe that the majority of
americans certainly not the majority of
people who regularly take airplanes and
travel
support the mass mandate you know why
because i've seen lots of videos
when the announcement came out of people
in the air and the captain the pilot
says you can take your masks off
and i don't hear booze and i don't hear
cries i hear the whole plane cheering
and so you i know that the ruling class
their their entire argument these days
is don't believe your lying eyes but i'm
sorry i still do i still trust my gut a
lot more than cooked up statistics and
the propaganda being pushed out by the
corporate establishment press i just
don't buy it can't wait to breed that
sweet air of freedom later this is not
not a winner for democrats
you know how i know this because one of
the candidates for governor of florida
nikki freed who is so
low in the polls it's almost a joke ron
desantis is running away with the
florida gubernatorial race
but nikki freed is is trying to do
anything she can to appeal to florida
voters and she just
just posted on the internet about how
happy she is that she no longer needs to
wear the mask nikki freed tweeted out
quote peace out to the tsa mask mandate
but also peace and respect to others
whether wearing a mask or not she's
sitting there on an airplane without a
mask on her face so she's trying to
appeal to to the common sense
whatever the ap says whatever the libs
are telling you about their polling the
democrats in practice don't really
believe that people like the mass
mandate that is why they're publicizing
how they're not wearing the masks and
they respect everybody but they're
really happy that the mandate is gone it
shows you that there's a big gap between
reality and the propaganda being pushed
out by the washington post and and
others
that's that's all the democrats have got
the democrats can try if they if they
want to win they can try to be the
republican light they can try to adopt
some of the republican positions but
that's not really going to work because
the republicans are going to be much
better republicans than the democrats
are going to be and then they can pull
some stunts and try to appeal to the the
absolute lowest passions and desires of
the people this is why the same
candidate nicki freed tweeted out
yesterday on 420 the national national
haitian oregano holiday she tweeted out
a picture of her standing with a bunch
of cannabis holding holding a leaf in
her hand and she says as governor i'll
legalize weed
yeah i'm not a i'm not a regular
politician i'm a cool politician i'm a
cool mom i'll legalize weed
okay well let's see ron desantis in
florida gave us a good economy and
political rights and they stopped the
perverts from transiting the kids and
and he's just he's done all these great
things and he's brought business there
and he's kept civil liberties and the
traditional way of life and you are
offering me
a blunt
uh okay not a really compelling argument
shows you how little the democrats think
of their voters that they think this is
a winning message
now sometimes when people puff on the
old haitian oregano they get a little
bit hungry i'm hungry all the time which
is why i love good ranchers go to
goodranchers.com
knowles i have been eating good ranchers
probably three times a week i love it
the steaks are phenomenal the chicken is
magnificent they've got some great
seasonings and things on the chicken
chicken's fabulous and then my absolute
favorite are the burgers the wagyu
burgers are really really magnificent i
don't really get how good ranchers works
because the quality is absolutely top
shelf
the prices are extremely low so you can
go in and order this meat just a one-off
get the box of meat it's all american
100 high-quality american meat and then
you can inflation proof your orders if
you subscribe to good ranchers you get
your price locked in forever i don't
know how it works but i think you should
take advantage of it while this
incredible deal is going on prices for
beef are only going to get higher as the
summer approaches your favorite cuts are
going to be harder to find lock in your
price and supply with good ranchers
right now get your 30 discount on prime
steaks and better than organic chicken
today goodranchers.com knowles save on
the quality you've been looking for good
ranchers takes all the guesswork out of
the grocery store sources everything
from local farms right to your door use
that code knowles and enjoy your box of
100 american meat and your 30 savings
combat inflation with good ranchers
american meat delivered
you know when the daily wire says
they're going to change the culture by
creating it they mean it we mean it
that's what we're doing here which is
why when disney was exposed for actively
indoctrinating children into their
leftist ideology the daily wire
announced that we are investing 100
million dollars into creating a platform
for children called dw kids not only are
we taking on kids entertainment we are
working around the clock to create
content that is purely and simply
entertaining from movies like our
upcoming release terror on the prairie
with gina carano to comedy shows like
truth yeller with adam carolla there was
no rock staying unturned and it couldn't
be done without your support if you want
to be a part of creating culture we can
all be proud of head on over to
dailywire.com subscribe use code build
the future for 20 off your membership
right now we'll be back with a lot more
joe biden is underwater
florida democrats are way underwater
democrats around the country are looking
ahead to an absolute republican title
wave in
2022 and potentially in 2024 in large
part because of this realignment in
large part because
nice middle-of-the-road parents who used
to vote for dems are now siding with
republicans the working class which used
to side with dems is increasingly siding
with republicans you're seeing
a shift you're seeing a realignment call
it whatever you will and because the
democrat politicians
are are just not popular joe biden
not making a strong case for himself
buddha judge not making a strong case
for himself nikki freed in florida not
making a strong case
and then we've got my favorite
my absolute favorite kamala harris
who just showed up to give a speech
to the space force
kamala harris has very
high level speech writers at her
disposal kamala harris could make the
play right now joe biden is old he's
it's hard to imagine he's going to run
for president again this is her chance
to shine kamala what's the best that
you've got to inspire americans to elect
you in 2024 or 2028
space is exciting
it spurs our imaginations
and it forces us
to ask
big questions
space
it affects us all
and it connects
us all
i think kamala harris has been hanging
out with nikki freed
in that green house
with all that peruvian parsley she does
this all the time i actually have a
kamala harris bong that i guess is not
unfortunately it's not at my desk right
now but i i'll have to spark it up in
order to even have a shot at
understanding what she's saying but from
what i can gather what kamala harris is
saying is
space man
you know
like you ever think about it man like us
but space
you know man
that's the substance
of her speech
and there there's actually a
a serious point to this
the democrats are talking in platitudes
right now and cheap slogans right now
because if they actually discuss the
substantive political agenda that
they've got they're going to look like
creeps and they're going to lose the
elections
that's the problem for democrats that's
why the democrats are trying to shut up
libs of tiktok if the democrats and the
libs were confident in their message if
they thought that their message was
going to win over a majority of the
american people they would love libs of
tick tock i love media matters
i love when media matters or right wing
watch or any of the liberal operative
groups clip out parts of my show because
then those clips go viral and i think
man those are great clips man i was
totally right there boy i put that
pretty well i think that's going to
resonate very often when these left-wing
operative groups cut out clips of my
show to try to get me fired i retweet
them because i think that's good stuff
man thanks a lot publicists
the libs don't do that
the libs try to shut down
conservatives who expose what they
believe and so in kamala harris's
defense what's she going to say what's
she going to say she's going to go give
a political speech and say we absolutely
must trans the kids we absolutely need
to pump five-year-olds full of cross-sex
hormones and puberty blockers that's our
substantive agenda for america we need
to give vladimir putin a pipeline so he
can invade ukraine we need to give a
nuclear bomb to iran we need to
flood the country with millions of
illegal aliens
we need to
keep your economy shut down we need to
keep you from going to church we need to
we need to we need to everything that
they want to do is unpopular
so truly the best they can muster is yo
man
you ever think about space if i'm your
governor i'll legalize weed kids hang
loose cowabunga that's all they've got
and it's pathetic and i don't think it's
working
because the american people are a lot
smarter than that if we can see it if we
can see it people who are listening to
this show right now probably play pay
pretty close attention to politics
you're probably i'm not just flattering
you you're probably a little bit more on
the informed voter side of things you're
probably a little more civically minded
but a lot of people just go about their
lives and they don't really have time to
pay attention to politics they don't
have a particular interest and so they
believe what they are inundated with
from hollywood and from the corporate
establishment news
media and what they see on social media
which is now an enforcement wing of the
liberal establishment
google facebook and twitter
control 90 of the flow of information
around the internet so
if you're just a casual internet user
what you are seeing is coming through
the lens of the left
which is why it's so important
that we crack up the left's monopoly on
big tech and that is very possibly going
to happen the the update on twitter the
musk update for today because you
remember elon musk bought a big chunk of
twitter then he was offered a board seat
but he turned it down because it would
have limited his power then he tried to
buy twitter then the corporate board
issued a poison pill to try to stop musk
from buying to tw twitter so it seemed
like it was over then but now elon musk
has a backup plan
just like he promised us he did elon
musk a few days ago tweeted out
love me tender
love me tender name of a great elvis
song
a lot of people didn't know what that
meant
but i suspected what that meant was that
elon was going to make a tender offer
which is when you go around the board of
directors and you go right to the
shareholders in twitter and you say to
anyone it could be to an institutional
investor could be a retail investor like
you or me goes in and says hey i'm
willing to offer you 54 bucks and 20
cents per share you want to sell it to
me and so he doesn't have to deal with
the board then just yesterday elon musk
tweets out blank is the knight
he's referring to tender is the night a
very famous novel and a line from a poem
by john keats
a poem oddly enough coincidentally
providentially intentionally that uses
the word musk in it
so i think it's it's clear elon is now
going to try to make a tender
offer
and and it's it's important not just
because
a tender offer would be a way to get
around the board and get around the
censorship and actually restore some
semblance of fairness and freedom to
twitter
but it's important because it shows you
the whole political strategy right now
the the libs are focusing on a corrupt
small elite to maintain their power and
silence the people and the conservatives
are relying on a billionaire to go
directly to the people to go directly to
the shareholders to try to bring back
some semblance of democratic politics
you're seeing it in high finance you're
seeing it in technology you're seeing it
around the country the realignment is
real folks i'm michael knowles this is
the michael knowles show we'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
michael knowles show is produced by ben
davies executive producer jeremy boring
supervising producer mathis glover
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer danny d'amico
associate producer justine turley audio
mixer mike coromina and hair and makeup
by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
today on the ben shapiro show the left
rushes to disney's defense as florida
targets the massive corporation's tax
breaks the cdc seeks to reinstate
federal travel mass mandates with a
legal appeal and the biden
administration tries to split the baby
on drilling as today on the bench bureau
show give it a listen